in the aftermath of the devastating
Black Tusk assault on the White House a
number of essential Personnel were
forcibly abducted leaving a void within
the ranks amidst the ongoing efforts to
reconstruct the castle sediment the
rescue of John Yazi a vital team member
is an absolute priority as his expertise
and contributions are indispensable to
the mission's success
agents locate John and bring him home
thank you
[Music]
following the traumatic events of his
helicopter being targeted in a
subsequent rescue at the Mexican embassy
John is confronted with a deep-seated
fear and reluctance of returning to the
skies
okay
he's sleeping better
not really
yeah
back in the Hilo
surrounded waiting for your agents to
get me the hell out of that Embassy
that's normal it should get easier
that's what the doc said
he'd give you anything to help you sleep
I don't think he had anything to give
not like we've got a fresh supply of
sleeping pills lately
I could get you some wine from the
theater settlement if you want
yeah just what you need a drug native
vets thinking of the White House I'd
rather have you drunk than dead
I'll be all right
not if you don't get some sleep
I just need something to do help take my
mind off what happened
we can always use a pilot
honestly Manny
I'm not ready to get back in the air
but if you need help with maintenance
and Logistics I'm happy to make Fernanda
and Casey's lives easier
that sounds like a great first step I'll
let Torres know she's got a mechanic
incoming many reaches out to Jon who is
dealing with PTSD many assures John that
he understands and empathizes with his
current struggles while John
acknowledges that he's not yet ready to
resume flying he expresses a desire to
stay occupied by offering to handle
maintenance and Logistics tasks for the
other Pilots
that's good it's going to be working
again
nice to be able to contribute
you ready to get back up there
honestly
no
that's okay
I haven't had a nightmare in a couple
weeks but it's just
it's too soon
I get it
I'm sorry
it's okay
no I feel like I'm letting you down
you're not
but I do have a favor to ask you
anything
I need help setting up the castle
if we want to have transpo in and out of
the site I need someone who can tell me
if I'm setting up everything wrong
last thing we want to do is move
everyone in and then discover we can
move supplies you're looking to build a
landing site
yeah
well it's safer if you don't put it in
the middle of the settlement if we can
land there so can our enemies that's a
good point
so what do you say
you want to help me rebuild the castle
despite time passing John remains
hesitant about getting back into the air
understanding Jones apprehension many
presents them with a new opportunity
recognizing Jon's expertise many assigns
from a crucial role in the cleanup and
rebuilding of the castle segment
specifically focusing on tasks such as
establishing a landing site and
continued helicopter maintenance
everything is cleared and we have an
underground entrance that leads into the
settlement
if you don't know it's there you might
think we were ghosts disappearing Into
the Night
that's not creepy at all
it was Eva's idea you've been spending a
lot of time on the lately
she's a good kid reminds me of my little
sister but funnier
she's funny I think she has a crush on
you
she reminds me of my little sister
don't worry Manny you're the only one
trying to start something at the castle
I don't know what you're talking about
I'll be sure to tell Mario you said hi
John has embraced his new
responsibilities at the settlement and
has excelled in his role with the team's
Collective effort they've successfully
cleared a fresh Landing site and made
significant progress in setting up the
necessary infrastructure
throughout this journey John has formed
a close bond with Eva whom he cherishes
like a younger sister finding comfort
and support in their friendship
I'm sorry Manny but I really don't know
if I'll ever be ready to fly again
I figured as much
you've got a landing site but no pilot
I've got Pilots
and I've got a coordinator and a
mechanic that will make sure they get
home safe
you're not disappointed in me why would
I be disappointed
you've done everything you said you
would and you've gotten Eva to open up
and trust us
your new sister is even talking about
taking over the radio station
that's great but I'm a pilot who can't
fly you have to be at least a little
annoyed with me
if you lied to me and got back up there
with a team and got everyone killed then
I would be annoyed with you
but you telling me what you need
I can't be annoyed about that
takes too much energy to be pissed at
someone for not meeting unrealistic
expectations
Okay so seriously what has Mari done to
you you're all like calm and reasonable
and Zen or some
she helped me realize that some of my
priorities may have not been that great
and like it or not we're family now and
I'd rather have my new brother safe than
trying to be something he's not and
putting us all in danger
so you're okay with me organizing the
pilots and maintaining the fleet more
than okay
that's exactly what we need
John confides in many expressing his
doubts about either being able to fly
again
understanding John's feelings many
reassures him revealing that he had
anticipated this outcome yet emphasizing
that his contribution in supporting the
pilots is equally valuable
moreover John's presence has been
instrumental in assisting Eva and
helping her to open up and developing
trusts in the community
John also observes that many appears to
be more relaxed than usual speculating
that Murray's presence may be
responsible for this positive change in
his demeanor
intelligence had recently surfaced
revealing a significant lead on the
whereabouts of John Yazi the Southwest
District of Washington DC became the
focus of attention as reports pinpointed
his presence at the choke control point
division agents wasted no time in
preparing for the mission in a
calculated and coordinated assault the
agents stormed the control Point
engaging in a firefight against the
entrenched black task forces
however as the agents fought their way
through the facility they received an
update John Yeezy has been moved by the
Black Tusk to the nearby train tracks
adding an additional layer of urgency to
the mission
they needed to act swiftly in order to
intercept them before they managed to
get away with Jon
[Music]
first agents would need to neutralize
the target echo1 otherwise known as John
train steward
as they made their way through the train
tracks They encountered waves of black
dusk forces that stood in their way
despite this the agents pushed forward
eventually they would find train and
attack him head on
however once he was eliminated agents
would intercept black task comms that
confirmed that John Yazi was dropped off
at the NoHo control point 10 minutes ago
by the recruiter
with urgency the agents proceed towards
the no Hope Hotel
upon arrival they wasted no time and
immediately got to work and eliminating
the Hostile forces that occupied the
compound
as the agents cleared out the threats
and brought the hotel under their
control it was then that many's voice
was heard over the comms saying that
John Yazi had been cited at the Rayburn
house
frustrated that they had missed him
again they knew that time was a factor
and quickly made their way over to the
building on the Eastern side of the
district
[Music]
at the Rayburn house agents would
encounter waves of Black Tusk forces
however through the fighting they would
get disorientated and eventually lost
in frustration they would punch a deer
to their surprise this didn't help and
it would be another 10 minutes of
running around in circles before they
realized where they needed to be
eventually they would find and confront
Black Tusk leader Dave Rhino bishop and
while they were able to eliminate him
all the time wasted earlier on meant
that they had missed Jon once again
many announces that Jon has now been
found he is at the Space Administration
HQ
the agents again blaming the deer vowed
to come back later on venison is on the
menu tonight however first they must
catch up with Jon for three years yet
again moved on
CE at the facility the agents pushed
forward through the hordes of Black Tusk
however their progress was abruptly
interrupted when they were ambushed by a
rogue agent
despite the challenging encounter the
agents persevered and triumphed over the
Rogue although they did question their
decision to undertake the mission with
the added difficulty of four directives
it was discovered that the btsu
operative Gabriel Dynamite Gonzalez was
holding John Yazi hostage
while the division agents were busy
taking care of dynamite and her troops
jtf forces successfully Infiltrate The
Compound and Rescue Jon
no PTSD
you sleeping okay
I'll let you know tomorrow
I just got home Manny can I at least
wash the black test stank off me before
you start the interrogation
sorry you're right
look I know you're worried about Mari
but you really don't have to be
they were good to me I'm sure Mario will
be fine she's worth more to them alive
anyway
what do you mean
your woman is brilliant
she's like a super genius when it comes
to this whole sustainable fish stuff and
she's pregnant
I don't know if you've noticed but
haven't seen a lot of pregnant people or
kids running around
what are you saying I'm just saying
if I were trying to rebuild civilization
it would be way easier to indoctrinate a
baby than an angry teenager who
remembers what the before times were
like
to keep people in line and follow orders
you get them when they're young when
they're desperate
people with hope who know better
those people are dangerous
kids
don't know any better
they learn what you teach them
they believe what you believe and if I
were going to build a cult
let's start with the kids
that
that does not make me feel better
after the successful Rescue Mission many
reaches out to John to check on his
well-being
sensing the need for a moment to gather
himself before diving into an official
debrief John requests some time to catch
his breath
however many consumed by worry for
Murray's safety overlooks the importance
of giving John the space he needs
fortunately John understands Manny's
concerns and reassures them that Mario's
safe and is being looked after
there are a couple key points here that
I'd like to address firstly the mention
of the recruiter for those of you who
may have forgotten he is presumably the
leader of Calvin mcmanus's Hunters that
we brushed paths with not so long ago
of all people I find it a bit odd that
an individual of his caliber is involved
with the relocation of a civilian that
is being held captive and even weirder
that we didn't see any Hunters during
this mission
effect instead we are greeted by an
unnamed Rogue these two things have
generally been considered contradictory
to each other and then to top it off Jon
would tell many that the Black Tusk has
actually been good to him like they're
trying to come off as the good guys
I've alluded to this in the past with
the black task aiming to be the
legitimate Heroes of this event in human
history
but maybe I'm reaching a bit here it's
just something about these three things
feels completely off to me
honestly I don't know what to make of
this at this point but I feel like it's
something we'll be hearing about more in
the next season or two
in John's comms there were a couple of
references to someone called Eva based
on one of the other Targets in the
season that we are to rescue this is a
reference to Eva Garcia she was a
student at Kinley College
I'm actually looking forward to a rescue
mission at Kinley sharana podcast with
very Rick velasi type conspiracy Vibes
including a number of references to the
phallus type nature of the statues that
can be found on campus
if you'd like to learn more about Eva
Garcia I have a video on Kinley college
that should be on screen but for now
thank you very much for watching and
extremely smallest extreme remedial
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]